oh my gosh it looks so gross
we committed to a technique of facial
capture which was extremely
underdeveloped at the time this is my
concept art
so the reason that shot looks the way it
is is because you put it together here
how would spielberg give feedback on
visual effects it's funny you should
mention that
thanks to expressvpn for sponsoring this
video stick around so you can see how
you can get three months free
hey what's up welcome back to another
episode of visual effects artist
reaction we have alex laurent on the
couch today he is nick's dad sitting
behind the camera filming us right now
you guys know nick well this is his dad
a legitimate industry professional
how can you lead with legitimate
right right so we got an illegitimate
industry professional with us today i
have been a visual effects art director
that was my official title when i was at
ilm and all the film projects i've
worked on since so what a visual effects
art director does is designs the look of
everything that's added in
post-production so it's basically
designing all the cool effects that you
see all right first up we're gonna be
looking at saving private ryan
i kind of feel like the scene
marked a shift in war films kind of
going from like a hollywood war film to
starting to attempt to show the reality
of war in battle people were not used to
this kind of brutality shown in such
documentary style then now it's
commonplace but i think at the time it
took a lot of people by surprise i think
there's something that's really worth
noting is that the chaos of like bullet
hits happening everywhere and tracers
flying everywhere is something that just
did not exist in films until you could
start doing digital compositing yeah you
could do special effects you could do
squibs but like you wouldn't be able to
do the like you know who cares they're
in the background kind of squibs you
would be able to do just like the little
hits happening here and there it's that
chaos that you're talking about being
able to just take this wide brush and
paint over an entire scene with that it
just it elevates that chaos and like you
said we hadn't ever really felt that
before until you know a scene like this
really pushing the feeling that you're
in the terrifying circumstances with
these heroes
[Music]
yeah those bubbles was bcg yep all the
trail bubble trails and blood bursts oh
yeah i can see the difference between
the trail bubbles and the real bubbles
yeah but in motion in an action you
don't notice the difference it doesn't
draw your attention as being fake you're
just looking at bullet trails underwater
and going wow they're in even extra
danger it's also worth noting that
outside the fact that you know you don't
want to shoot bullets at your actors
bullets don't actually penetrate water
deeply so they'd have to be visual
effects for them to go down that far
that's like the one lee way i feel like
they're taking this scene with like the
physics yeah but that's a pretty common
trope you know having their bullets
going through the water but the slow-mo
guys proved and dustin that you can't do
that a lot of what ilm did was add that
extra danger that extra layer of chaos
that of course would have been a danger
to the actors on set
do you see the body fall down across the
screen there and that explosion goes off
and that dirt explosion goes out oh yeah
yeah that was a dummy
yeah
war so funny
oh i remember this
the red dot on the forehead is like a
classic digital like bullet hit effect
you see all the time these days just
tracking a little dot you're done but
notice how they had a little bit of like
some like knuckley flesh coming out the
back of his head before the actual mist
sprays out
oh my god wow dude look at all the
zeppelins they're known as barrage
balloons i found out about those
from
talking to
a veteran and i decided to introduce
those as a compositional element into
that shot this is it
this is the this is the con my this is
my concept art over a clean plate
just a tank maybe another vehicle or two
about a dozen troops marching up and
down so this is the concept painting
photoshopped over the plate and then
there was a matte painting and a lot of
2d two and a half d and 3d elements that
were composited over the actual shot
itself so the reason that shot looks the
way it is is because you put it together
here
pretty much yes wow you need to do your
research so i ended up not only
consulting all of the places you'd start
history books with photographs of what
it looked like on the beach but also
ended up basically cold calling a bunch
of veterans associations and historical
associations so i was able to base the
design of this wide shot on as much
historical fact and accuracy as i
possibly could what blows me away is how
close the concept art looks to the final
thing they just used your photoshop file
they actually didn't it's pretty these
trucks right here are the same exact
trucks right there yeah it's so easy to
forget when you're watching a movie that
everything has been built or treated and
that's a whole process that rarely gets
talked about is the concept design
process and you go through many
different versions of any given design
before they finally approve how would
spielberg give feedback on visual
effects i remember spielberg as always
being extremely polite and good natured
he had a good sense of humor and he was
just professional i don't think he would
get overly technical he would leave that
to the others on his team he would make
his comments from the director's point
of view the narrative importance visual
importance and he always kept the
perspective as any good director should
that it's not about the effects it's
about the story and the entire thing
yeah the effects need to serve the story
always and that's the kind of thing he
would say and we'd go
yup that's why he's who he is
[Music]
so you also worked on the second mummy
movie as well yes the mummy returns
this one has the most famous bad visual
effects shot of all time
so i've heard it called and by some
people so yeah he fixed it all right
you fixed it so what's the problem a lot
of what you guys revealed in your
redo of the shot in analyzing it was
pretty spot on and really points to the
limitations of the day like many effects
from this whole era in the 90s we can't
expect to look back at them and expect
them all to hold up to today's standards
what was the hardest part what was the
point where you went like
we can't get it to work like what was
the face it was the face and if i recall
we committed to a technique of facial
capture which was extremely
underdeveloped at the time we all knew
that this was falling short of what we
would like it to be when you're
confronted with a situation like this
where your best hopes and dreams aren't
quite panning out it might be time to go
call for the old lessons more yeah show
less i know we tried to use lighting to
be our best friend i feel like there's a
big attempt to
help lock him into the scene by having a
lot of really dynamic lighting all
around him so you can really sync those
up with the 3d model and get it
absolutely right that's the exact same
thing we did with our luke skywalker
deep fake where we're like you know deep
fakes handle light changes just great so
like let's have a bunch of sparks and
things flickering to like put them into
the scene i mean that reveal is a pretty
sweet shot what's up the composition the
silhouette the camera move it all works
really well yeah and i will say i'm
super proud of the work of the animation
team and the art department man the
artwork was gorgeous and the whole
process of building it was super
exciting it's just a little bit uh
the getting the face right it literally
just comes down to the face
as we've come to learn a lot over the
last couple decades the uncanny valley
is real and absolutely unavoidable
tomorrow on corridor crew i think we can
recreate the famous trench run scene
from a new hope in a day our idea is to
do it as easily and casually as possible
while still having it look better than
the original movie you guys better be
careful because disney might be coming
after you
so you also worked on minority reports
we're going to take a look at that we'll
have to look at minority report another
time to go into further vfx detail but
you got some really interesting stories
that i'd love to hear today absolutely
so got a shout out to the film's
production designer alex mcdowell and he
designed all the sets and he was
stephen's partner in visual design on
this they
spent a year or more before production
ever started doing the deepest kind of
research and exploration investigation
into what the future would look like
spielberg was so interested in taking
the original short story written by
philip k dick and updating it in a
realistic way this was not supposed to
be a fantastic sci-fi world of the
distant future but all like relatable
futurism and sure enough this film has
managed to be prescient and predictive
of a lot of the tech that we have now
including things like gestural
interfaces
[Music]
we got animatics of a lot of these
scenes this one included and a lot of
concept paintings beautiful work from
the studios art department so here's
here's more art this is one of those
amazing paintings from the art
department at the studio done by gerner
but then we replaced all of this this is
warren foo and my art team here
basically redesigning and replacing all
of this ground level stuff to guide the
map painters when they replace all of
that our job was take that grand vision
and compress it down into what was
pretty small number shots and to do it
all on a budget
also let's just take a moment to
appreciate how tall this building must
be
it's funny you should mention that
that's one of the problems i had a lot
of fun solving was simply how tall are
we going to pretend these buildings are
and this is where just good
old-fashioned cinematic lying and
cheating comes into play and there's no
apologies for it we love it and it is
all reverse engineered from the needs of
the edit so they had a rough edit they
knew the pacing they knew the basic
beats and almost all the shots framing
had already been decided because they
used those to guide their filming of tom
on the set basically we built as many
yards and stories of this building as we
had to the same basic idea as you see in
all those old hanna-barbera cartoons you
know this constantly running sideways
you know the background it's to say you
see the same building go by like the
flintstones if they're in the car and it
goes by i mean we did that in mario's
skate where i was going down this
alleyway and the alleyway is not that
long but in the edit basically i ended
up going down that alleyway several
times by the end of that sequence it's
just like shots are just completely
reused different angles and you need
things like that uh you know shots like
this those balconies you need a
horizontal line of some sort to mark how
fast we're going yeah in fact i designed
all of these anonymous futuristic air
conditioning units these things that
just stick out they have no purpose
really just for this purpose so that we
could just have a repeating kind of
something architectural piece going by
because otherwise it's just the lumpy
streaked motion
thing you need that visual context to
indicate speed and you were talking
about building right wow you actually i
literally planned out how high up in the
air can we get and so here you actually
estimated how tall the building is and
at what point did it start looking kind
of fake and feeling silly spielberg
would always be telling us he did not
want anything in this future to look
sci-fi-ish or pushed to the point of
being fantasy-like right i hated that
look that most future sci-fi cities had
and he wanted specifically to work
against it so the cement we used was
just like cement you know the materials
had to feel dirty yeah there's
definitely a grunge aesthetic going on
in this movie that really kind of
grounds it in reality what's the matter
can't sleep so yeah one creepy thing in
this movie is the fact that he had to
get new eyes
one-eyed man
and that's the big gross
you don't often see like eye sockets in
movies certainly not full on he wanted a
good gross out moment to drive the point
home i'm seeing the challenge of hair
being in front of the cgi socket that
they have to replace it's a really cool
shot the one thing that bumps me a
little bit is how bright the inside i
was noticing that too the right eye
socket i don't disagree so i ended up a
little over lit they probably wanted you
to really see the parallax to feel like
oh it's sunken in because you can't do
makeup that subtracts from the face like
you know voldemort's nose missing you
know you can push somebody's nose down
but it's still something there you have
to do that through cg for the eye socket
you think they just like rendered out
like i mean it wouldn't be that hard you
just like you get some cups and you just
texture it gross skin and then you
render it out pretty close actually this
was a fairly straightforward simple shot
it needed to be designed and then
approved the level of sort of grossness
so my job was to quickly generate the
look of what this eye sockets would look
like and not have them be too gross
gross enough but not too gross
and that's when i decided i was going to
stop trying to fake it with hand
painting and i was going to photograph
something real you photographed
someone's eye socket yeah i went out
basically no i didn't have to i didn't
have anyone who was willing to give up
their eyes like in the movie so what i
did instead is i grabbed my favorite
sculpting material sculpey and i made an
eye socket that i sculpted but i still
wasn't happy with this look because i
wanted to get into the visceral skin
stuff i wanted to see some stitches
right i wanted to see some sutures so i
went upstairs to the kitchen and in the
fridge was a chicken a bakery a chicken
a roast chicken you know the kind you
get in the deli maybe my wife had
had bought that a day earlier and this
was the leftovers and i thought bingo
there's the chicken oh my gosh
gross i peeled the chicken skin off and
i sewed this disgusting sutured eye
thing here it looks gross just looking
at it right even though you know what it
is it's still like yes which is the
right reaction your wife was going to
make dinner with this chicken so she
gets home she's like all right i'm gonna
make dinner you're like sorry i'm making
minority report
this is the final photoshop comp that i
gave to the compositing department this
piece of chicken made it into the final
film they used this exact thing yeah
they obviously like put it into a 3d
space
for the for the actual shot but that's
the same texture basically i believe the
compositor took the art itself from my
photoshop file and basically just do a
simple projection over a simple piece of
geometry to give it some curvature in
parallax if i remember correctly that's
why it's pretty crazy yeah so those are
the original eye socket elements for
minority report
now you know now you know the rest of
the story i do really want to look at
minority report again sometime there's
so much going on there's definitely more
that we'll have to break down from a
minority reporter leave a comment down
below if you think there's a specific
scene from minority report that we
should check out
it's come to my attention that there are
individuals on this here channel this
very channel in these integration
sections who are trying to take my spot
gunning for my job is what they said i'm
coming for jake's job
gunning for my job well
[Music]
i am so sorry that you just had to see
that but what i think that he was
getting at was our sponsor today
expressvpn think about it have you ever
been in a crowded room trying to take an
important phone call but imagine your
phone's on speaker that's what it's like
browsing the web without a vpn
expressvpn encrypts your internet data
preventing others from sniffing your
information when you're using a public
wi-fi network without a vpn you're
putting your personal information in
danger if a hacker steals your
information online they can open bank
accounts in your name access emails and
access your social media expressvpn is
so easy to use you just connect with one
click they also have some of the fastest
speeds consistently faster than other
vpn providers the other amazing thing
about expressvpn is they allow you to
change your location to almost anywhere
in the world allowing you to access
content normally blocked in your country
when i found out that the office had
been taken off of netflix in the us they
might as well just said everyone you
love is dead
dead and then i found expressvpn it's
like my family wasn't dead they just
moved to canada
that's all it was we just moved to
canada i can watch the office forever
so if you want access to content from
all around the world go to
expressvpn.com
corridor crew and find out how you can
get three months free
this is already one of my favorite
episodes we've ever done simply because
you're able to bring this artwork here
and i was able to hold it in my hand
like
so cool like i think back to like when i
was you know i'm so inspired by ilm and
also that kind of stuff and then it's
days like today where it's like i can't
believe i made it this far and i get to
sit with some of the people that have
made this stuff and hear these stories
and then share it with everyone else and
hopefully pass on that inspiration that
inspired me so much if you guys would
like to see more of alex's art you can
follow him on instagram at alexander
laurent or you can go to his website
alex laurent.net very cool all right
guys it's an honor to be here thank you
so much thank you so much for tuning in
as well we'll be here tomorrow and we'll
be here next week stay tuned we got some
cool stuff thanks for watching